oh my god a long time oh no so happy to
have you here yes I missed you so much
you love yes I love you that's kind of
my thing
yeah so nice to say you look gorgeous
thank you are you in the Christmas you
know holiday spirit spirit I'm getting
ready you know I'm excited I like it I
spend a lot of money in Christmas so I
want it to be over a little bit really
if you spent you buy a lot of gifts I
love to give gifts and then my business
manager is the one that doesn't get very
happy he says he said yeah what is this
just by you laughs yeah I can't wait to
see what you get me
it got creep me again so quickly you go
to a lot of holiday parties do you like
to party yes I love to party both my
friends and I love going to parties that
are like you know where there's music
with there's good food like everybody I
mean who wants to go to about party no
but you like you know what I happen to
know this Jesse Tyler Ferguson was on
the show he showed us pictures of you
dancing with his husband and they're
costing ya and you're you're leaning way
back it seems to be we have a few of
these it's a it's the national party
yeah and then a casual party and then
this seems to be you seem to talk that
was that was not really nothing
happening he was like he was a loose on
yes well anyway no better way to ring in
the holidays I say I like having fun I
like dancing and jousting he's a very
good dancer
so when I don't have anyone to dance I
grab Justin that's very nice you know
what speaking of dancing I dance with
your boyfriend Joe you know now he's
really getting creepy well no he was on
the show and of course he's in Magic
Mike and he's gonna be in the sequel and
I saw him dancing with eagle yes well
that must been a very a real erotic
surprise for you but he was teaching me
some dance moves and it made me wonder
do you ever give him pointers when he's
you know on what how you would like him
to move he's Magic Mike no he moves
perfectly I don't have to give him any
pointers but you know it's like it's fun
- it was fun to see him prepare for
Magic Mike it was you know a little bit
like surprise him because I didn't know
that he could dance like that um but it
wasn't out of fun he did a lot of crazy
things in the movie yeah I think he even
had an accident you seem all broken up
about it so so many things because I was
doing like some crazy is 3 per routine
and and the the girl that he was with
doing this 3 / 4 and did something wrong
and things went wrong so he he got hurt
he got hurt he's dangerous to be a
stripper I thought it was just fun and
games but that's why I gave it up yeah
[Laughter]
no one says creepy like you let's I just
want to ask you a quick question which
is you have you're a fashion icon people
love your fashion they love your sense
of style tell us just for men advice
lowrider jeans for men do you like to
see men in lowrider jeans real low-cut
jeans I don't know that's a very
dangerous one and tricky when I prefer
not to yeah I mean unless I don't know
unless you're like 15 maybe it would
work but I don't know 15 no yeah creepy
I think some of those things I certainly
don't let's take a quick break we'll
consult with our lawyers we'll be right
back more with Sofia Vergara stick
around
[Applause]
you